et des compétences les allumoirs vers
une entente plus ou moins cordiales
alors que le transfert de compétences
empoisonne les relations entre la
majorité départementale de françois
sauvadet et les équipes de la métropole
dijonnaise et françois rebsamen depuis
plusieurs mois un premier rapprochement
semble avoir lieu le transfert de
compétences c'est ce qu'a réclamé la
métropole comme elle invite la loi pour
gérer notamment le tourisme la voirie
les personnes âgées les jeunes en
difficulté et c'est sur ce volet social
que les tensions étaient fortes pour la
gauche ce transfert est une évidence le
but de tout ça c'est simplifier la vie
des gens quand même faut pas l'oublier
et quand vous habitez dijon que vous
émettez quetigny aller pour le départ à
au département pourra prêtre redirigés
ailleurs face à ressemble à rien mais
françois sauvadet s'est posé en
défenseur du département pas de
disparité entre campagne métropole sur
le volet social il a obtenu que si le
premier accueil se ferait à dijon le
département gardera ensuite une
compétence sociale
il y avait des revendications qui était
assez incroyable de vouloir prendre
toutes les compétences du département
firent finalement comme le modèle
lyonnais qui est aujourd'hui récusé par
tous donc voilà c'est une étape
maintenant c'est le préfet qui doit
déterminer les moyens financiers
notamment pour le transport de nos
routes sur la métropole puisqu'on va
transférer des routes départementales
donc on va transférer des agents les
moyens car les désaccords demeurent sur
les moyens et les charges à transférer
les deux entités ont jusqu'au 1er juin
pour s'entendre à défaut le préfet
tranchera
si pour moi voilà mon père